what is up everybody it's annamac here
for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down
and explaining the ending of the attack
on titan story
including the new pages that have been
released
pages that add to the final chapter and
expand
the ending in multiple ways my brother
goes then who also makes videos here on
the anime uproar channel already did a
full review
of the final chapter back when it first
came out
but i also wanted to give my thoughts on
the controversial
attack on titan ending and these new
pages which essentially create
a new expanded ending present the
perfect opportunity to do
just that so in this video i will
explain the ending
of this iconic series i will address the
various criticisms of the ending
and i will give my own personal opinion
on the ending
and on the series as a whole now that we
finally know how it ends
if you enjoyed the attack on titan
content here on the channel
and you want us to keep it going just
leave a like and comment
it's a quick and easy way to support the
channel and of course if you're new to
the channel or maybe you watch our
videos but you haven't subscribed yet do
me a favor
and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
your support really makes long videos
like this
possible i'll talk more about patreon at
the end of the video but first
please be advised that we are of course
covering the attack on titan ending so
spoilers are incoming
proceed with caution okay now let's dive
into the ending itself
including the expanded ending with the
extra pages
the ending started off with a lengthy
and candid conversation between
aaron and armin and this conversation is
happening in the land of the paths
it took place around the time that army
and annie were talking on the deck of
that ship
back in chapter 131 aaron made armin
forget about this conversation after it
happened
but armin remembers it again after
mikasa kills
aaron this conversation between the two
of them was the source of a ton of
controversy
many fans felt that parts of it just
weren't consistent with the characters
of armin and aaron and some
even felt that the conversation undid
the development of
aaron's character aaron's plan was to
push armin and mikas away from him
because he knew that he would have to
play the part
of the villain he knew that he would end
up destroying 80 percent of humanity
and he felt that he had to do this in
order to save the aliens on parodies
taking out marlei and all of ld's
biggest enemies and sparing only the
nations that were like the furthest away
from elder would level the playing field
quite literally so this would give the
audience on parodies
time to develop modern technology to
defend themselves from future attacks
however aaron couldn't bring himself to
go all the way
he didn't want to kill 100 of humanity
beyond the walls
so he wanted armin mikasa and the
anti-aaron alliance to stop him
that is why he didn't take away their
titan powers and he wanted them to
eventually take the credit for taking
him down
and for saving humanity or at least
what's left of it
that way the humans who were left alive
would see the aldians who stopped aaron
as heroes
rather than enemies which would
hopefully delay any future conflict
between aldians and the rest of the
world
and here we already have the first big
issue that many people had with this
ending why would aaron go to the trouble
of killing 80 of humanity outside the
walls
but not the remaining 20. if he's
already willing to kill
millions and millions of people then why
wouldn't he just go
all the way the answer is not 100 clear
but it could simply be that aaron wanted
humanity to survive
in the long run if only the aldians on
the island survived
then one major natural disaster or even
a civil war
could lead to the destruction of all of
humanity the other possibility is that
aaron believed that paradise
needed other humans in order to stay
united if the people on paradise
knew that somewhere across the ocean
there were other nations who were
potential enemies
then they would unite behind the idea of
defending themselves against
that common enemy in the future and so
they would be motivated to keep
progressing
as a society if the people on parodies
knew that they were the only people left
in the world they might get too
comfortable so they might stop thinking
about progress and eventually they could
just start fighting amongst themselves
until they wipe each other out in some
brutal civil war
but with that being said i definitely
recognize that there is a jarring
dichotomy within aaron's character
in the final chapter and this bothered
many people
from this conversation with harmon it is
clear that aaron
at the very end of the story is two
radically different beings
at once on the one hand he is still a
traumatized and vulnerable teenager with
unstable emotions but on the other hand
due to the founding titan power
aaron is also a semi-omniscient being
for whom the present
the past and the future all exist at
once
this means that aaron is trying to
juggle two radically different
existences within himself
and to be honest it is practically
impossible for us as readers to
understand
how that would even feel maybe the
closest we can get to understanding
someone who exists in the past
present and future at the same time is
the concept of ujji
or being time which was developed by
13th century zen master
dogen but even that is not the same
thing
after the activation of the founding
titan power within him
aaron is both human and radically
different from human
at the same time and so in this final
arc
it is often impossible to tell where the
eren we know
ends and where the collective
consciousness of the founder begins
that brings us to some of the biggest
issues that many fans had with the
ending
and that is aaron's character itself in
the final chapter
aaron implies that back when reiner
bertolt and annie first attacked
shiganchina
it was actually aaron himself who
compelled the smiling titan to walk
past bertolt and towards his own mother
aaron said he did this because he knew
that it wasn't yet
bertolt's time to die but critics of
this moment couldn't understand why
aaron would want his own mother to die
and for everyone on the island to suffer
if he had the power to change it what
was the point of this entire battle
against marley
if aaron had the power to change at all
from day one but didn't
but here's the thing i don't think that
aaron the character we know as
aaron jaeger had the power to change it
i think that he experienced this event
as part of the founding titan's massive
collective consciousness
so for him it felt like it was actually
him doing it and guiding the smiling
titan
but it wasn't really him it was the
founder of which his consciousness was
just
one small part don't forget about carl
fritz's famous
valve pacifism because this phenomenon
proved that the founder can
fundamentally change the consciousness
of its current holder people like yuri
and frida reese were committed to
end the vow of pacifism and protect the
people of paradise before they inherited
the founding titan's power but then
as soon as they became one with the
founder they completely
changed their minds i think that
something similar
happened to aaron he wasn't bound by the
vow of pacifism himself because he
didn't have royal blood
but his consciousness was fundamentally
altered once it became one
with the collective consciousness of the
founder this means that aaron wasn't
really free
after all as much as he claimed to be
pursuing freedom
in the end he was still dependent on and
perhaps even subordinate to
the founder i'm not saying that he had
no will of his own
but this will was just one of many wills
within the founder
and in the end it seemed that emir fritz
was the one who
called the shots when we saw mikasa kill
aaron in order to stop the rumbling
despite the fact that aaron was the man
that she loved
emir stopped the rumbling and apparently
removed the titan powers
now i know that many fans don't like
this implication that aaron was not
really free they wanted him to achieve
his lifelong goal of attaining true
freedom for himself
and for his friends but the question of
are we free
is not a simple one and it's hard to say
how much of what we do is
our own free will and how much of it
depends on things like our
upbringing our specific cultural and
social context
and even fate itself if fate is
something that you believe in
the other problem that many fans found
with aaron's character was the fact that
at one point in the final chapter
aaron seems to revert to a childish
state
when armin asks him if he would be okay
with mikasa moving on and finding
someone else
aaron says that no he can't stand the
idea of her being with another man
aaron also says that he doesn't want to
die he just wants to be happy with
mikasa and his friends
but as much as he would love to do that
he can't just hide away and pretend that
most of the world
isn't preparing to destroy the island of
parodies so in the end
aaron decided to initiate the rumbling
not because he's some alpha mega chad
but because he believed that it was the
only way to save his friends
and the woman he loves and this really
pissed some people off
so you're telling me aaron is cool with
destroying most of the world and killing
millions of people
but he's upset because mikasa might end
up with another guy
i've heard so many people argue that
this moment destroyed
all of aaron's character progression and
made him revert into that edgy
overdramatic team that he was
earlier in the story but i have to say
that i disagree
with this interpretation it might be
hard to understand that one person can
be both
a nearly omniscient being and a
vulnerable teenager at the same time
but that is exactly what aaron is don't
forget that
at the end of the attack on titan story
aaron is only 19 years old
he's still just a teenager and on top of
that he is a teenager who had an
incredibly difficult and traumatic life
combined that with the fact that his
consciousness
ended up melding with the
incomprehensible collective
consciousness of the founder
and are we really expecting aaron to be
an emotionally
stable person are we really expecting
him to suddenly forget all of his trauma
and
immaturity and become the greatest chad
in all of anime
that would have been far less faithful
to his character
than the reveal that back when he was
having a private conversation with his
best friend aaron had a moment of
weakness in which he said that he wanted
mikasa to just be with him and no one
else
aaron even asked armin not to tell
mikasa about this
because ultimately he did want her to
move on and be happy
he just wasn't thrilled about the idea
of her being with another man
and i mean who can blame him he's still
just an emotionally immature teenager
and if you've ever been a teenager
yourself and you had a big crush on
someone
you probably went through many immature
and melodramatic feelings and thoughts
at that time because let's be real
that's just how most teenagers
are i don't think that this moment takes
away from aaron's character progression
at all
in fact i think that it shows us that he
is still human at least
some part of him still is even after he
became the
founding titan now let's talk about
mikasa and emir
because the connection between them
ended up being an extremely important
aspect of the ending
and another major point of criticism
aaron reveals that the real reason why
emir fritz was so loyal to the fritz
royal family for
thousands of years is because she
actually loved king fritz
even though he was a cruel and horrible
human being and even though he was
literally her abuser she loved him and
the family that they had
together so that is why she chose to
sacrifice her own life to save him
and why she continued to obey the fritz
royal family even from beyond the grave
at the same time emir's love had
enslaved her
and she wanted someone to free her from
the world of the paths
that someone who would eventually free
her turned out to be mikasa
because even though mikasa truly loved
aaron she was willing to kill the love
of her life for the
sake of others for the greater good
after she saw mikasa making this
heartbreaking choice
emir decided to follow in her footsteps
and she chose freedom
over her love for king fritz the extra
pages revealed
that emir had been peaking inside of
mikasa's mind
throughout her life which implies that
emir's intrusions into mikasa's mind
through the paths is what caused
mikasa's headaches
before this extra page was added the
question of why mikasa had those
headaches was still
unanswered but now we finally seem to
have an answer
speaking to the vestige of emir after
the death of aaron
mikasa acknowledges that emir's love for
king fritz must have felt like a never
ending nightmare at the same time that
relationship
as tragic as it was produced emir's
three daughters
who became the ancestors of the modern
eldians
without them mikasa and everyone else on
parodies probably never could have
existed
emir then briefly envisioned a different
past a past in which she allowed king
fritz to be assassinated
and lived on with her three daughters
this is definitely how things
should have been and i wish that this
had really happened but unfortunately
emir sacrificed herself to save
king fritz and then he went on to force
her daughters to consume her remains and
carry on the power of the titans
throughout the generations
as mikasa says goodbye forever to emir
and emir's vestige evaporates the very
next image that we see
is of historia's daughter i don't know
if this is supposed to be a hint that
emir may have been reincarnated
into historia's daughter or if it's just
supposed to be symbolic
but i could totally see his story on
naming her daughter emir
in honor of her fallen comrade from the
104th training corps
now while i did appreciate the inclusion
of these extra pages
especially because not knowing why
mikasa was getting those headaches was
really bugging me
i can understand why a lot of people had
issues with amir's character
and her motivations if i'm being honest
i don't think that emir fritz
is a well-written character her
motivation for serving the fritz family
is not unrealistic unfortunately in the
real world there are people who develop
feelings for their abusers and that is
why abusive relationships can persist
for years
and even decades but the fact that
emir's motivations aren't
unrealistic doesn't mean that they
constitute good writing
i think that her character and backstory
could have been developed a lot more
thoroughly
and her motivations for serving the
fritz family could have been more
interesting and more complex than just
oh she loved king fritz when we compare
emir and her character to so many
other characters on attack on titan she
just doesn't measure up
and that is unfortunate because as the
founder she could have been a lot more
interesting this is just my opinion
though i do understand where the
criticism of her motivations is coming
from and
i tend to agree with it another
criticism that i absolutely agree with
is the claim that the ending was rushed
the final chapter felt
extremely rushed so much stuff was
crammed into one single chapter
and there wasn't nearly enough time for
isaiah to properly expound
on all of these events even with the
extra pages
chapter 139 still feels rushed
and this is painfully evident during the
conversation between
armin and aaron many critics of the
final chapter
said that during his conversation with
aaron arman acted in a way that is
inconsistent with his character namely
instead of arguing more aggressively
about the rumbling and instead of
becoming enraged when aaron refused
to stop it armin just kind of accepts it
and even thanks aaron for becoming a
mass murderer for the sake of his
friends
armin also seems to get more upset at
aaron over his treatment of mikasa
than he does at his decision to murder
millions of people
i totally see where this criticism is
coming from and i think that the
extremely rushed dialogue between aaron
and armin
is the cause of the problem more time
should have been spent on armin trying
to come to terms with the reality of the
rumbling and trying to accept the fact
that even though the rumbling is
horrifying
it is the only way to save parodies from
total annihilation
i also think that more time should have
been spent on explaining how the
collective consciousness of the founding
titan works
and more emphasis should have been
placed on the fact that aaron is now two
beings at once
a human and the collective consciousness
of the founder
for aaron who experiences the past
present and future
at the same time the rumbling was
inevitable something that had to happen
but for armin who is just human
this is not the case armin cannot see
the future like aaron so in his mind
so many other alternative solutions
could have been implemented
solutions that don't kill off 80 of the
world's population
more focus should have been placed on
this conflict between armin's
perspective as a normal human being
and aaron's perspective as a
semi-omniscient collective consciousness
after armin remembers his conversation
with aaron he takes the credit for
killing aaron in order to take that
burden
away from mikasa aaron had told armin
that he can still journey beyond the
walls
and save humanity and armin ends up
doing that as a sort of diplomat
as the hero who killed the evil aaron
armin tries to foster good relations
between parodies and the rest of the
world
in the aftermath of the rumbling but
that's where the next major criticism
comes in
knowing what we know now especially
after those extra pages were added at
the end what was the point of all of
this
when in the end war inevitably broke out
again and paradise was still destroyed
after the rumbling ends and aaron is
killed titan powers
apparently disappear and in the final
chapter it is implied that this could be
confirmed
through blood testing in theory this
means that the world doesn't need to be
afraid of aldians anymore
the big aldean villain was aaron and he
was defeated by
other aldians now these other aldeans
are all just
normal people they are no longer titans
which means that the rest of the world
doesn't need to be afraid of them
at least theoretically however the
aliens and parodies are not just
counting on theories to keep them safe
three years after aaron's death the
jaegerists have created a modern and
professional army that is ready to
protect the island in case one of the
surviving nations
ever decided to attack at the same time
the heroes who took down aaron became
ambassadors for peace and they are
trying to preserve
the peace among the surviving nations
through diplomacy
so parodies is using both military
deterrence
and diplomatic relations in order to
protect themselves and preserve the
peace
which is in essence what nations do in
our own world they try to have
good diplomatic relations with other
countries but at the same time they also
try to have the strongest military
possible
in order to protect themselves if
diplomacy fails
meanwhile mikasa is not one of the
ambassadors
and we see her just spending time at
aaron's gravestone
which is located beneath the tree on a
hilltop she is wearing the red scarf of
course
and she talks about wanting to meet
aaron again
then as the scarf begins to slip off her
neck
a random seagull appears and puts the
scarf
back on before flying away looking at
the bird
mikasa says thank you for wrapping this
scarf around me aaron
and this is where the original chapter
139 ends
before the extra pages are added
naturally
the bird thing created a lot of
controversy
is this bird supposed to be the literal
reincarnation of aaron or
is it supposed to be aaron somehow using
the bird to reach out to mikasa from
beyond the grave by using what's left of
the paths
or was this just a massive symbolic
coincidence
i was not a big fan of this scene
because it is a bit too on the nose
for my liking the scene seems to be
implying that the bird is somehow
aaron himself and without more context
or an explanation of how reincarnation
would even work in this world
it just seems jarring so no i was not a
big fan of the bird
thing but now we need to talk about the
new ending because this is where things
really get spicy we quickly move
multiple years
into the future and we see an older
mikasa with what is presumably her child
and her husband visiting aaron's grave
and placing roses on it
mikasa's husband's face is not shown but
from behind he looks a lot like jean
and so people are assuming that it is in
fact jean then even more time passes and
we see that mikasa
is an old woman now she appears to have
had multiple children
and grandchildren and it is important to
know that the tree looks considerably
bigger now
than it did in the previous scene and
also if we take a look at the tree's
surroundings
a sprawling city has been built all
around it
when we first saw this tree there is
nothing but nature
anywhere close to it the town was off in
the distance
but now the town has transformed into a
city and expanded all the way up to the
tree
and beyond this tells us that parodies
succeeded in modernizing
and industrializing and so they must
have caught up to the rest of the world
in terms of
industry and technology sometime after
that we see that mikasa has died of
old age and she was buried with the red
scarf
aaron gave her some people assumed that
she was actually buried right next to
aaron but that is not necessarily the
case
we don't see where exactly she was
buried but it could have been anywhere
also i saw a bunch of people complaining
about how mikasa being buried with the
scarf
meant that she never got over aaron and
so she never really loved her husband
who is presumably jean
and then i saw some of those people
complaining that jon was a [ __ ] and all
this other nonsense
this is such a juvenile interpretation
of events that it really makes me wonder
how old people who make these comments
are obviously an individual can love
more than one person over the course of
their life
and just because mikasa still loved
aaron doesn't mean that she didn't
also love her husband in the real world
there are many people who tragically
lose their spouses and become widowed
and then eventually remarry
the fact that they remarry doesn't mean
that they stopped loving their first
spouse and the fact that they still love
their first spouse doesn't mean that
they can't also love their new spouse
i didn't think that this even had to be
said but apparently it does
as time continues to pass the tree
beneath which aaron was buried continues
to get larger until his gravestone is
completely hidden away inside a cavern
beneath the massive tree
we then get a glimpse of the distant
future probably like 80 to 100 years
after aaron's death a war using modern
weapons technology is raging
and this includes aircraft and
anti-aircraft rockets
the military technology we see here is
equivalent to the tech that exists in
our own
modern world we see high-rise buildings
being bombed
into oblivion by jets and then we see a
post-apocalyptic
aftermath the booming civilization that
had developed over the past 100 years
now lies in ruins but aaron's tree
continues to grow and now it is
absolutely
massive it is just as massive as that
tree that emir fritz had stumbled upon
2 000 years ago this indicates that many
more years
must have passed since that devastating
modern war
took place a child with dark hair and a
dog
are seen walking through this
post-apocalyptic world
and the story ends as the child and the
dog come upon
aaron's gigantic tree based on
appearance alone
the child looks like he or she could be
a direct descendant of mikasa
and although this is not the same tree
that emir came across when she became
the founding titan
isayama's intention here is to create a
clear parallel between the two
scenes more than 2 000 years after emir
another child finds itself in front of a
similar tree
in a similarly war-torn world and
that is the end of the story there were
of course
multiple criticisms of these final pages
so let's start with the criticism that
the entire struggle of the story was
pointless because in the end paradise
was destroyed
anyway i do not agree with this
criticism because the message of attack
on titan was always clear
war is inevitable it is an unfortunate
part of human nature
and it can never be completely avoided
attack on titan does not buy
into the progressive view of history
which suggests that history is a steady
progression towards a better future
and which implies that world peace will
one day be possible
attack on titan ascribes to the cyclical
view of history
which suggests that history keeps
repeating itself because no matter how
much
time passes human nature remains the
same
human nature itself drives people
towards conflict
so while methods of waging war may
change and the circumstances surrounding
conflict may change
conflict itself remains a constant and
yet
conflict is not the only constant the
other constant is that somehow
someway humans will find a way to
survive
just as the ancient marlians survived
the alden empire and just as the aldean
minority survived marlene oppression
and just as 20 of the world survived the
rumbling some humans managed to survive
that
apocalyptic modern war that we witnessed
in the final pages
the fact that a child is alive after so
many years
means that after the war some people
survived including the child's parents
grandparents and so on
all the way back to the war itself
humans are resilient
and they are likely developing a new
civilization on the ashes of the old one
as we speak now you might personally
reject isayama's view of history
you might think that history really is
progressing towards a better tomorrow
and towards world peace but this ending
is absolutely consistent with the
overarching message of attack on titan
up to this point aaron didn't succeed in
saving parodies for
all of eternity he managed to save his
friends he managed to prevent the
impending destruction of paradise by the
marlene
allied armada and he gave the islanders
time to develop
and catch up to the rest of the world
but after that
human nature was bound to kick in once
again
it was only a matter of time and it
seems that it took about 100 years
before war erupted once again
i actually liked this addition to the
story and i felt that it meshed
perfectly with the rest of attack on
titan
this story was never some idealistic
shonen story where in the end the good
guys win and world peace
is achieved and any ending where the
world is at peace forever
was never going to happen some think
that aaron destroying the entire world
instead of sparing that last
20 would have changed things but i
wouldn't be so sure
even if the only people who survived
were the islanders on parodies
internal conflict is still a thing civil
war
is still a thing and so on even before
the marlans attacked paradise
they still had internal strife conflict
and oppression
within the walls themselves and even if
aaron had wiped out
everyone beyond the island some type of
conflict was still
likely to happen in fact for all we know
that final apocalyptic war
could have been some form of civil war
between rival factions on parodies
finally i want to talk about all the
rumors about a potential sequel
which stems from the fact that this
child from the future stumbled upon the
same type of tree as emir did
2 000 years earlier as the theory goes
aaron's head
which lies beneath that tree has become
a new
spine-like creature and once this child
enters the cavern beneath the tree
aaron's new centipede thingy will attach
itself to the child
just like that other one did to emir and
titan powers will return to the world
as this child becomes the next founding
titan
this is intriguing although i don't
think that an actual sequel
is likely that said i do think that
isayama wanted us to think about this
possibility and so he left the ultimate
outcome of this final scene
open for interpretation i mean the
similarities between the two trees
could just be symbolic but if they are
then why did both
emir's tree and aaron's tree grow to be
so freaking big as compared to all the
other trees around them
is this just a special breed of tree or
did it become like this
because the spine-like creature itself
is influencing the tree's development
honestly this is a fascinating question
and even though i don't believe that
there will be a sequel
i really like the open-ended nature of
this final scene
it is both disturbing and intriguing at
the same time
and it is highly thought provoking so i
definitely approve so
after covering all of that what do i
really think
of the ending i thought that it was okay
at best the original ending was probably
like a 6.5 out of 10 in my book
and the additional pages actually bumped
it up for me to like a 7.
that said the overall attack on titan
story is easily a 9.5 out of 10 for me
and i think that it remains a
masterpiece and one of the best
fictional portrayals of the cruel
reality of war
if it had been up to me i would have
done the ending differently
it was definitely rushed some important
questions were never answered like
why was aaron able to manipulate
mikasa's memories at all when previous
founders could not affect the memories
of the ackermann clan
and in general i think that the final
character arcs of people like armin and
levi could have been handled a lot
better
but if you put me on a spot and asked me
how exactly
i would have ended the story in a better
way i wouldn't know what to tell you
that is the ugly truth about the attack
on titan
ending after over a decade of
anticipation
and after all of the hype surrounding
aaron's transformation and the rumbling
it was impossible for isaiah to come up
with an ending that would satisfy
everyone no matter what kind of ending
it was millions of fans would likely
hate it
a happy ending would have been
criticized as not fitting with the
overall themes of attack on titan a very
bleak ending would have left millions
asking what was even the point of the
entire story
and so on in the end i did not love the
ending but i didn't hate it and i don't
think that it takes away from the
greatness of the story itself
my all-time favorite anime is guren
lagan
but i was not a fan of what happens with
the main character at the very end of
the story
still the story itself was incredible
and the same goes for attack on titan
i have to say that i was very
disappointed with some attack on titan
fans
and even some attack on titan content
creators
many of them just jumped on the ending
hate train
without taking the time to actually
think the whole ending through
many of them falsely claimed that the
ending made the entire series bad
and they even started criticizing
isayama personally
and saying that he was always a terrible
writer this is absolutely ridiculous
and while you have every right to
dislike the ending attacking the author
after he spent over a decade bringing
this story to life
for your entertainment is ridiculous
isayama gave us an amazing story a
heartbreaking portrayal of the cruel
reality of
war and in the end he faced a very
difficult challenge when it came to
ending this long-running series
in a satisfying way you may feel that he
failed with the ending
and that's okay he's human and humans
make mistakes
but turning on the entire series and on
the author personally
because you didn't like the ending is
just petty and wrong
thank you isayama for the epic story
that you gave us
and thank you to all of you who watched
and continue to watch our attack on
titan videos here on the anime uproar
youtube channel
more attack on titan videos are coming
soon especially once the final episodes
of the anime arrive
so definitely subscribe and turn on all
notifications
so you don't miss them you can also hit
me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
outpour patrons for making videos like
this one
possible special thank you to alpha
sigma and
red haired raven these guys are absolute
mad lads
and disciples of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa
algertol dr cortman the toasted chi ry
carlo
slickback emperor otaku spidey life
chanel tungsten tarkis
baked buddhist and cody hebert finally
thank you also to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh angel cruz anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp
very gucci alicia octor bonnie park cino
kami and water 10 no ted isparky65
joanne garcia
fat boy games metal mama corey mcgowan
deadly saint soul ray slice and dice
and pillow if you enjoy our videos and
you feel that they provide value to you
consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you